avec vikash dhorasoo candidat aux
municipales sur la liste des six dans
paris bonsoir vikash dhorasoo merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france quel est votre état d'esprit en
ce premier jour de déconfinement plutôt
le soulagement la quiétude plutôt le
soulagement oui j'ai plus besoin d'une
attestation pour sortir de chez moi
c'est un grand soulagement
voilà déjà mais je me sens toujours pas
libres du tout voilà ce jeu on a ce
confinement et puis toutes les mesures
qui ont été prises et puis les libertés
que ce sont quelques compris le
gouvernement mois m'enlève beaucoup de
mes libertés
je me sens plus aussi libre qu'avant et
ça c'est le plus important et pourtant
moi je j'ai eu un confinement
pas trop dur je j'imagine pour que pour
que pour les personnes dans les
quartiers populaires dans les quartiers
plus difficile ça doit être encore
compliqué aujourd'hui ils doivent se
sentir encore pas tout à fait libre
alors on vous attendait pas forcément là
vikash dhorasoo parce que c'est vrai
qu'on a vu cette rébellion sur le
confinement plus tôt dans des pays plus
en zoo anglo saxons que le libéro des
gens qui ont justement réclamer le droit
notamment d'aller travailler qu est-ce
qui vous a si des plus dans ce manque de
liberté pour vous il n'y avait pas une
nécessité impérieuse tout simplement
pour une raison de santé de devoir
rester enfermé chez soi et d'obéir d'une
certaine façon au gouvernement toute
façon j'ai l'impression que le
gouvernement ne consultent plus personne
on n'a même pas eu le droit à une seule
fois à poser des questions aujourd'hui
ils le
les prises de parole c'est nous imposer
quelque chose sans arrêt alors on les
sent pas très sûrs d'eux et en plus on
ne peut pas questionner n'y a pas eu de
conférence de presse les journalistes
n'ont pas pu poser des questions on n'a
pas pu proposer autre chose une autre
façon de faire
il y avait peut-être d'autres solutions
il y avait peut-être quelque chose
d'intermédiaire
mais dès aujourd'hui on nous a confiné
au new déconfite comme ça arbitrairement
du jour au lendemain du dic c'est le 11
et puis deux jours deux jours deux jours
avant le confinement où on nous avait
dit d'aller voter
quelques jours plus tôt le président
nous disait qu'il fallait le au théâtre
et puis du jour au lendemain il fallait
être enfermé aujourd'hui le le ministre
de l'éducation nous dit que les enfants
c'est mieux qu'ils aillent à l'école
alors que ya pas si longtemps c'était
dangereux pour eux de croiser un autre
copain et de jouer au football par
exemple sur un petit square donc on n'y
comprend rien et puis je trouve ça très
autoritaire voilà moi c'est nos libertés
qui sont nos libertés fondamentales qui
sont remises en question et et sous
prétexte de la crise sanitaire voilà il
ya beaucoup qui beaucoup de gens qui
disent que le christ héritèrent ne peut
pas nous imposer quelque chose
politiquement si vous aviez un peu
changé quelque chose qu est ce que vous
auriez changer justement qu'est ce que
vous reprochez finalement le le plus au
gouvernement de ne pas avoir anticipé
rang en amont parce qu'il plus important
et ce qui est ce qu'on a pu voir le plus
c'est des gens qui n'avaient pas la
possibilité de manger et je pense que
dans une démocratie un pays riche comme
la france tout le monde devrait avoir la
possibilité de manger alors au niveau
local au niveau local ça devrait être
une obligation de prévoir ce genre de
problème est que ce soit pas la
solidarité des gens parce que les gens
se sont mis en mouvement parce qu'il ya
une énorme solidarité qui s'est mis en
mouvement mais ça devrait être une
responsabilité permanent de pouvoir
donner à manger à tout le monde tout le
temps et on l'a vu c'est possible il ya
de l'argent dans ce pays
l'argent en france ça devrait pas être
que la solidarité ça devrait être aussi
une une obligation politique on ne va
pas choisir entre la santé et l'emploi
il faut les deux
ce qu'affirme la ministre du travail mme
muriel pénicaud quelle est votre
réaction
on a bien compris dès la première
annonce du président la république
tendant le confinement que réouvrir les
écoles qui étaient plutôt quand même
pour que les les enfants notamment en
bas âge puisse être déposée pour qu'on
puisse soit retravaillé
je comprends en fait on est piégé parce
qu'en fait on à moi ce que je veux ce
dont je me rend compte très fort là
c'est que ce pays au ralenti nous a
permis de revivre localement alors sans
voiture sans pollution se promener
voirie jardin refleurir sortie à la
société de consommation ne plus voir de
touristes par exemple mais en même temps
il faut relancer toutes et toutes ses
économies néfaste pour la société parce
que sinon on ira à la catastrophe mais
en même temps il faut voir ce qui est
requis ce qui est bien pour nous et ce
qui est bien pour nous c'est peut-être
transition qui est souhaitable
alors là on relance l'économie parce que
y'a des gens qui ont besoin d'aller
travailler pour payer leur loyer
mais derrière il faut réfléchir à
comment faire en sorte de continuer ce
qui est ce qui était bien dans ce moment
là moi par exemple
j'habite à montmartre aux abbesses et
ben y avait pas les touristes y avait
pas la consommation il y avait la
possibilité de se promener
tranquillement dans notre dans notre
dans notre arrondissement
il ya aussi des solidarités qui ont
montré qu'on pouvait se passer de la
grande distribution qu'on pouvait se
passer de sodexo par exemple les
cantines dans xviiie arrondissement on
pouvait faire cuisiner local jo et
donner à manger à des gens et on
pourrait le prendre c'est ses
expériences et les utiliser pour pardon
pour les cantines pour la grotte pour le
personnel soignant pour les entreprises
et puis on a besoin d'un parc
on a bien vu que nous 8e arrondissement
ont été défavorisées on a pas d'endroit
pour se promener pour respirer
aujourd'hui on ré ouvre les parcs bayard
déconfinement de classe j'ai
l'impression on ouvre les départs que le
champ de mars le bois de boulogne le
bois de vincennes mais nous on n'a rien
est-ce que vous avez justement l'espoir
les choses ne redevienne pas comme avant
vous pensez que nous sommes amenés
justement nourrir
t comme le dit emmanuel macron sa
réinvention à lui je me méfie si c'est
pour relancer l'économie
et puis forcer les gens à travailler
encore plus on parle du dimanche d d d d
heures supplémentaires des vacances qui
vont être supprimés pour qu'on puisse
relancer l'économie ben moi je suis
contre par contre utiliser ce moment
pour sortir la société de consommation
faire des choses plus ensemble se voir
partager l'entr'aide panos erwin
aujourd'hui fait un beau papier sur
l'entr'aide comment faire les choses
ensemble et et voir la société
différemment à l'avenir pour prévenir
une autre crise qui pourrait arriver
moi je vois ce monde comme ça évidemment
se battre pour l'obtenir
alors la dernière question aller pour
l'ancien footballeur que vous êtes on
voit l'allemagne qui reprend son
championnat
la bundesliga est ce que vous auriez
aimé voir le championnat recommencé en
france justement aux beignets de
demandes de liberté est ce que c'était
l'une des choses que vous auriez
peut-être vos voeux oui oui carrément
oui moi je suis pour que je suis pour
qu'on qu'on retrouve notre liberté aussi
sur les terrains de foot mais aussi
ouvrir les parcourir les stades ouvrir
les squares pour qu'on puisse y aller
alors en respectant les les les mesures
les conditions de distanciation sociale
voilà pour respecte tout ça mais on est
capable de d'être raisonnable et je
pense qu'on est capable de reprendre le
le football de jouer au football
les autres pays les autres championnats
le fond si on prépare bien la reprise
oui et on serait capable aussi d'aller
au bout du championnat qui est un vrai
champion et un et qui se bat qu'on gagne
nos titres sur le terrain chausséa
dommage moi merci en tout cas vikash
dhorasoo d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes candidat aux
municipales sur la liste des six dont
paris merci d'avoir été en direct